the annual saint baldrick's shave event  was a huge success mcmullen's irish pub  hosts the event every year to raise  funds for childhood cancer research as  of 2pm today more than  875 thousand dollars was raised our  sheri swenskin bryan loftus emceed lynn  and brian mcmullen say they work hard to  make this event happen every year and it  was that much harder with covered  restrictions  it takes a village to make this event  happen we have an incredible community  of volunteers without which we wouldn't  survive but then we have this incredible  las vegas community and generosity  they have shaved 156 heads from 31 teams  the goal of today was 1 million dollars  the event just wrapped up a few minutes  ago  coming up next